almost every time I meet somebody they
say oh my gosh
you're like a regular height yes [ __ ]
I'm a regular height it's those guys hi
I'm Tom France and I'm about to be
quizzed on what I posted on my own
social media what four things made up my
superfab show busy Friday night I'm a
snarky [ __ ] so I assumed that it was
something blame probably Netflix sofa
carbs bed by 10:00 oh my god okay take
out robe notice their bed by 10:00
that's pretty damn impressive to
remember that from September that's how
glam my life is I usually I'm in bed by
10 o'clock but who is missing in this
photo a couple of comments to make it's
very important for me to try to look
tall I am 5 9 which is a perfectly
average height however I'm surrounded by
white Giants and Carano almost every
time I meet somebody they say oh my gosh
you're like a regular height yes [ __ ]
I'm a regular height it's those guys
that are okay who is missing in this
picture I know this all too well it's
Babu Gigi Hadid and she looks gorgeous
as ever and I would happily turn video
who made me emotional when I met them I
get really emotional a lot Claire Foy
baby I'm Vicky mouth ah walked into the
room he was there really excitable and I
looked and smiled and then as I walked
over to hug him I started to cry I
turned to my husband my husband was like
[Laughter]
35 and I'm crying at meeting Mickey I
miss Japanese blank what am I missing
from Japan toilets I know that sounds
really weird but that toilet seats when
you set the toilet seats are already
heated the first time you use it is so
weird like it's really jarring now I
really don't want to go back to cold
look cold toilet seats it's just not
nice now they don't encourage you to do
stores
so the blank is he's a tyrosine my
friend said oh my gosh that hair I said
thanks love this is going to sound
totally do she bought what did I say
here it's usually I'm running on day
three or four I don't do my hair very
often so I probably said I didn't
actually do it this is my bed err hate
me all you want it's not my fault I've
got a shin hair special special moment
with my boys can I remember what me and
the boys were wearing to the Emmys ah
I actually I know this
Jonathan was wearing a sheer blouse a
white Stella suit a purple the row
clutch Bobby was wearing a dark teal
Prada suit with a black lapel show us
tab France was wearing the most
beautiful Tom Brown suit that was
tailored to perfection with a Louboutin
heel and see Pross he was wearing balm
on a cropped black blazer with silver
buttons he was wearing a high-waisted
pant with a cummerbund and metallic bomb
on shoes Kurama Brown was wearing a
black juillet like an overcoat eating a
burgundy suit black riding boots a white
shirt black tie
ah he was wearing a burgundy tie come on
that was [ __ ] impressive picture on
Instagram my caption is to build to dope
Queens what or the Queen was posing in
this photo oh I'm gonna say the current
Queen and I don't know if she's like the
second or the third I'm a terrible Brit
I think it's the second let's say the
second it just goes to show what a
crappy Brit I am because it says 1902
2002 so it's not that long ago
I think she's one I think this Queen
what I think it's the Queen Mother
actually it is the Queen Mother I've
redeemed myself I'm ten France this was
back in timeline and I know my social
media of course I know my social media
I'm obsessed with it
you
[Music]